so you made a promise that you were
going to finish the film now who was
that promise made to was it made to
yourself first or were there other
people involved you yeah I mean getting
a film approved to shoot out at Burning
Man is is a process you submit a
proposal and basically I think burning
man wants to make sure that you're just
not out there you know shooting you know
shooting nudity or you know
sensationalizing enters yeah exactly
they want to make sure that people's
rights are protected and then you're out
there doing a documentary maybe about
the art or about a certain project or
documenting something that may be
already doesn't have a documentary
there's an amazing documentary called
gifting it which is all about a gift
economy and about how that works and the
extending and the way people interact
with people out there and so that's been
done you know it's a documentary it's
amazing and so I feel like anyways we
were really lucky to get our project
approved in 2008 and I think part of
that approval process was basically this
promise that I would that I would finish
the project because basically we were
pitching hay this crazy group of young
people are going to go out there and
we're all going to be involved and
there's all these multiple directors and
we're going to put something together
this was this the gist of our pitch and
we had a unique idea which was like
we're each going to contribute fifty
percent of our time so the other fifty
percent you know participate immerse be
part of the experience out there you
know the whole thing is that everyone
out there is a participant rather than a
standby or you know rather than somebody
just observing and so I feel like that
was part of kind of the uniqueness of
our project so yes I I was like okay
well I want to make sure that you
actually finish this and I said I can
finish it and so we sort of did this
handshake you know where I committed to
finishing it you know this was four
weeks before we went out on production
so it's like you know we got there we
got the permission to shoot and then
you know put the foot the project
together and then went out there and
things became difficult things became
incredibly difficult to make to make do
on the promise to actually say that
they're like I promise to finish it and
I did well how do you define that well
you know is it is it the film in a film
festival is it the film on you know on
it on a DVD like this is finished yes
you know depending on which definition
and now I feel like so this week so like
I think 14 days ago or 18 days ago we
finally launched the film onto online
platforms and so we finished the film we
had our film festival premiere and then
did all the work on the DVD the making
of the extras the DVD menus finished the
DVD and then just now we're finally
getting around to actually releasing the
film on online platforms where you can
actually watch the film online on places
like Amazon and Hulu and indie flicks
and Vimeo and PHX
you